Sons and daughters who are too old for me,
those who threaten my children, I
forgive you.Through the
watermelon-like four
lanes, the queen and the painful
windows, I
set sail in the name of Belgaimchrome.
[Music]
[Applause] The
power of magic.  A secret technique to bring it to its maximum level, to definitely kill it.
[Music]
If you increase its power with technology, it will surpass the seven crescent moons.
70,000 familiar explosions will never fail. A
prisoner of fire. Explosions?
[Music] Well
then, I'll teach you one thing in particular.  The
possibility of saving the witch is about the
Great Ruined Labyrinth, where there is a magician who can manipulate time.For the
sake of food.If we
continue to
defeat the demon, the
ninjas will be saved.But
for me,
[Music]
I
sorry